hey guys welcome back to the water LED
podcast thanks for tuning in to another
episode if you are you are officially
allowed for doing so and I guess I'm
officially a cantabra now I'm still
working on a studio I'm doing this one
for my garage but I guess that's the
beauty of a podcast you can literally do
them anywhere and speaking of Studios I
managed to get to oh Studio on the
weekend for my very first experience and
a float oh my God what an experience
that was felt like I spent 30 minutes in
space felt great afterwards it was it
was such a cool setup up there if you
are in Christchurch I do highly
recommend you go check it out and if
you're somewhere else in the world I
highly recommend you getting in touch
with Tim Bateman and starting your very
own o Studio there's a reason why the
wellness space is the second fastest
growing industry in the world and it is
only going to grow I can promise you
that and having the opportunity for
Timmy to guide you through a process of
setting up your very own o studio uh
would be such an amazing experience and
honestly if I had spare time or money or
both I would be all in on this perfect
for anyone who's thinking about
something to do Post footy or just a
career change if you're interested head
to O Studio to inquire and I'll leave a
link below also last week I went along
to Todd's Racing Stable and saw the
champion combo of Regan Todd and the
horse what a lad jeez he looks an
absolute picture he's coming along on
the track as well he's about six months
away from racing but I'm so hopeful that
everyone who's got involved with him
that we are going to have some good
times following this led on the track
massive shout out to Regan Todd for
sponsoring this podcast go follow Todd's
racing on Facebook and show them some
love but let's get to this one I've got
an absolute bad for you here
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh what a lady again guys I've somehow
managed to get on one of the games great
Lads this man has certainly been around
the teams having played for North otago
Hawke's Bay he was a Super Rugby winner
with the Hurricanes while he also played
for San Diego Southland New Orleans the
blues and of course he was a USA
international and even went to the Rugby
World Cup he has a very well respected
player from players all around the world
and he's always been known as a lad to
tell it how it is so I'm really looking
forward to this one with the great lad
himself Tony Lamborn welcome mate she's
my pleasure thanks for having me mate
great to get you on I do love getting
guys on who have recently retired a
couple of reasons it's always good to
you know go through their stories and
sort of reflect on their Journey but
um they've also got no reason to hold
back not waiting for any contacts or
anything not that you've ever really
held back anyway like I said you've
always sort of told it how it is
throughout your career
yeah that's um that's definitely me are
you trying to say that uh Lexi's uh
retired now
[Laughter]
surely surely not mate he's he's still
hoping for All Blacks though mate I hope
I hope that doesn't happen mate he's got
the rig for it does he what the man
boobs
mate how has it been like um the recent
retirement uh I didn't see this one
coming but and what was the reason
behind it oh I think it was just I just
felt the timing was right
um finished up last year with the Stags
and
um had a couple of games Club rugby and
got the got the 100 caps under about for
my um for Havelock North my club rugby
team um here in Hawke's Bay
um so just wanted to check that box off
um and then yeah I just I've got a
Building Company here in Hawke's Bay and
it's um going really well so it just
felt right I just think I needed to
transition to the my new season in life
and um yeah yeah it's to be honest it's
been a great transition and um could
have asked for for a better one to be to
be honest all right how good is your
body sweet like no injuries or anything
you're good to go nah nah body's pretty
brilliant today
um getting my thumb fixed after New
Year's and uh the other ligaments and
they're all gone and now I just
literally just pops in and out when I'm
mucking around on the building site
um
and got to get my ankle fused it's uh
another one
I literally walk around like a 60 year
old man on the building sites you know
so but nah like other than that
um just put on about 10 extra kilos and
living the dream really
well you've cracked it but right that is
the um I guess that's the downside to
the gaming like your body does get
absolutely ham especially um loose
forwards I could imagine like you must
have niggles everywhere like like you've
said your thumb yeah your ankle but
probably everywhere right yeah and I've
um I've definitely had my fair share of
injuries
um a few broken bones here and there but
nothing major I was pretty lucky to be
fair I didn't have too many um like
knees shoulder surgeries or anything
like that a few I had a couple of ankle
surgeries just clean ups and stuff like
that and I did have one pretty hectic
um injury in 2018 with the states
um I was in Romania of all places last
five minutes of the game
just yeah just had the ball or drawn
past down the edge as I do oh I put them
away no doubt Rick Razzle you know is
pretty much of a nickname not
um but yeah they just got tackle it from
the front the back and
too much weight on the old
on the shank and it just dislocated out
just out the side and never had an
injury like that before and I it was
quite a weird sensation it was like a
really warm
feeling and I didn't feel pain I just
kind of felt this real heat go through
my foot and through my ankles obviously
just the rush of blood like escaping
inside of your um under your skin uh and
yeah it would just kind of lifted my leg
up
and I looked over at the doctor and I
was like holy [ __ ] held me one he's
like what and I'm like just showed him
my lead I was like showing my leg and
it's just hanging out like this
I want my [ __ ] my leg mate
we're playing Ireland the next weekend
in Dublin and I was like hobbling off
they just popped my ankle back in and
I'm like looking at the head coach like
can you get here right next week champ
no dramas did you play oh [ __ ] bro I'll
just played footy for another like six
months she's just gonna say
but was it so like just a dislocation
nothing actually broke or anything no
they're just a ligaments would have been
stuffed that was the other one yeah just
ligaments were all rooted um
so they had a perfectly fine ambulance
there at on the on the field and uh
anyway the game had finished by the time
I got to it and hello someone turns up
in a
1998 Toyota Corolla get in the back
champ we're saving gas in the ambulance
I'm like what's going on here this guy
doesn't speak a lick of English in the
the um physio came with me I think and
she went to go sit in the front with
them
and I think those guys just don't like
women hey they always got no respect for
them she jumped in the front seat and he
lost his sugar and at this stage I'm
fuming because this guy's just having to
smoke it with all the other doctors and
all the other ambulance drivers out like
which I'm just sit in pain
and so I would just checking away I'm
just human he does that to the Physio
and I lose in it and I'm just like
bro get me to this hospitals anyway
they're like ah trying to make out it's
a private hospital I'm thinking oh
Beauty it'll be um it'll be nice you
know like it'd be legitimate
um doctors and surgeons and [ __ ] there
he'd get there's about four new four
nurses and like two doctors all have
darting at the front
I'm just like what's going on here with
this country get in there in this old
ass beat up chick man she just like
lovely lady couldn't speak any English
but she's trying to get me up on the
X-ray so I'm up sitting up there and
she's trying to place my ankle and I'm
like obviously can't move it yeah like
couldn't position it for it she's like
bang no no like placing it for me I'll
just say you're [ __ ] out of it do you
realize what my ankle look like about
half an hour ago Jesus Christ
that's good times yeah and then I flew
to Dublin the next day and
uh I went got an MRI and met this this
lovely lady that was a kiwi lady she was
in her mid-50s or something and it was
great to talk to someone from home and
she helped me through it mate what you
flew to New Zealand the next day landed
and my whole leg was black oh blowing
right up mate what a yawn to start jeez
man we're here we haven't even got into
it yet
that's one of the great Yarns to start
loved that but I am Keen to hear a
little bit more about uh what you what
you are doing next you mentioned
building you've said it's been pretty
smooth transitioned so far
um so what what is your role going to be
what are you what are you going to be
doing
um yes I've just the the building thing
was
um covered 2020
you know I just thought well I'm not
gonna I might as well get ready for
because I knew I was going to retire
within the next two or three years so I
thought my plan was to play in the next
World Cup 23 World Cup and then retire
after that
um and then the US didn't qualify they
obviously do going through the process
at the moment but yeah I was like well I
need to get something sorted you know I
don't want to
um I don't want [ __ ] to hit the fan once
I retire and then I realized you know
what have I got here
um so just started uh Building Company
and it was just me and my fortunately my
brother's got a really successful
company Building Company up here as well
and um gave me a couple of houses to
build
so just me and the old man gave me a
hand when I needed him on two men and
then I employed um a good friend of mine
Penny cololatu
um played with them back in the day at
the magpies and stuff like that and um
he was pretty Keen to be able to see he
gave me hand and
and yeah over the last two years it's
grown from just being me to now I've got
um eight Builders and uh
and yeah just got pretty much 23 is
fully booked
um new houses and uh or new builds and a
few massive Renovations and stuff like
that so now I've got my um got my work
cut out for minutes for sure but I'm
loving every minute of it
um appreciates different different
pressure to the rugby environment uh I
guess like the rugby like the pressures
kind of like performance and stuff like
that whereas
uh
this kind of pressure is just [ __ ]
remembering what I've got to do you know
I'm just like looking at my door like oh
geez oh my God yeah
like I said I'm really enjoying it it's
um it's good I like that pressure not
saying I didn't like the rugby pressure
I felt like I thrived under the pressure
you know did you work um
one of the great yeah
do you think you'll miss rugby though
oh I definitely miss it I said to the
boys like one of my best mates Gareth
Evans wake up like he literally lives
like 200 300 meters down the road from
me and um we're chat every single day
pretty much
um and yeah I just I just said to him
look I I missed the playing I missed the
game I missed playing it but I do not
miss the training I don't miss the yeah
just uh the gym
um the fitness testing you know any of
that [ __ ] I just I love playing the
game yeah just letting out some of that
frustration and that competitive that
competitive energy out there yeah that's
that's about it really I'm enjoying all
my boys my uh my oldest son jack is uh
he's six and he played Ripper the last
two years so I coached his Ripper rugby
team this year yeah it was a bit of fun
it was just kind of mucking around he's
not really into he doesn't really give a
[ __ ] but are kind of making him do it
anyway
um I was I actually was one of those
guys it was like nah I'm not going to
make my kids play rugby they can do
whatever the [ __ ] they want not thinking
that my kid didn't actually want to play
rugby
he's he's pretty bloody good at it but
anyway we I had a lot of fun with that
and I think I had put my hand up to help
um
help where I can with the with the
premium team oh nice yeah about north of
here pass that knowledge on yeah
something like that I don't know just
wing it I think I've winged it the whole
way I think we all have to be honest
yeah yeah but anyway I'm kind of freak
and I definitely wasn't one of those no
no neither here but anyway I do always
like to um start from the start with the
journeys uh see where it all started for
them
um so where did it all start for a young
Tony Lamborn
um so I was born in summer and uh and
then grew up in ashburton in the mid
Canterbury Dairy farming background
um didn't it didn't know too much about
rugby didn't really give a [ __ ] about
rugby
um knew I wasn't actually quite athlete
I was pretty fast and and strong
um and so I was into Athletics I was
into the high jump long jump and all
that type of stuff and you're 100 meters
sprinting all that what age was this
This was um artist Primary School
through the intermediate and then just
before high school I started um started
playing
uh one of my mates one of my good
friends Ben Bailey um he was one of my
of my he was my the my best mate growing
up you know through intermediate and
through um primary school and that he
might be he might watch this later on
he's
um could fully LED down a Christchurch
yeah good to see Ben uh and yeah he
asked me to play and so I chucked me on
the wings is obviously pretty quick
and just took off from there I was into
it made uh Rick teams every year from
there on and then you know you get a few
um if you hears on your balls and yeah
yeah you start growing a bit taller a
bit bigger and um still managed to hold
my speed but uh yeah start getting a bit
too big for the wing we were in my age
so either Chuck me in the loose foods
and I need to look back mate what age
did you go into the Lucy's oh I think it
would not have been
um probably about
14. oh yeah oh yeah yes I played I
remember playing my first game when I
was about 12 or 13 yeah and just quick
ass love that yeah yeah yeah I was
pretty I was lightning lightning right
and you left scope you left school
pretty young hey what was it yeah
um I left uh ashburton College when I
was just turned 16 and went and went for
the old man the old man was like oh look
you know good at this you know you got
at the school [ __ ] but you might as well
I guess like
use use some sort of whatever you've got
in the top two and just can't work for
me so
this stage augmented sold all his funds
and um and pretty much had retired but I
was bored shitless so he's doing lying
uh laying tiles and stuff for his good
friend Dave Taylor
um and so I just started laying tiles
and then my brother had a roofing
company so I was helping him with his
roofing company and then 2008 when I was
16 I moved up to Hawkes Bay just wanted
something different wanted to change I
knew it wasn't going to become um any
kind of like I never thought I was ever
going to crack in rugby but I just
wanted a challenge you know I wanted
something different so yeah moved up to
Hawkes Bay 2008 and um went to Havelock
North Rugby Club and as a 16 year old
and I was like yeah
I'm here to play for the prims and I'm
like yeah number 21 boys I was 16 year
old playing under 21s for the next uh I
think it was like two or three years
and then I managed to get a licking with
the friends in there and then you just
stuck they stayed in it from there
correct how did you find that as a 16
year old playing in that League oh I
don't know I just I think my first year
was kind of just I I came in about
halfway through the season so kind of
got a just a good look at off the beach
and hit some real good lads in the team
you know like
some guys I still look up to this to
this day like just absolute Lads and um
took me under their wing and you know I
gotta um got my cousin's ID so I was
like they're taking me out in the purse
and I learned to grow up real quick
um
I think I was about 90 kilos dripping
wet but um that was all good another 21s
so obviously a lot of questions came in
about your dues stories you obviously go
really good on a do you run a good do
um I'm guessing this is where it all
sort of started for you as a 16 year old
following the you know 21 year olds and
then throughout your career always being
that sort of young guy in the in the
older cultures yeah I definitely wasn't
surprised when uh he gave me a little
little peek at some of those
um yeah you know just I'll have a good
do get real excited for it always that
guy that's pushing for as many
um Court sessions throughout the season
you know
um love always being at the head table
um so I can just control the situation
get everyone drinking piss
um don't get me wrong you know there's
like times have changed since when I
like when I first had my physical
sessions and stuff like that like you're
a dick if you don't drink piss if you
don't drink if you don't drink beer like
now yeah like don't you're not even
welcome don't even sit down yeah
um but these days like there's a few
boys
um that don't drink and stuff like that
that's all there's no dramas these days
so respected so yeah still welcoming you
in and um get you doing something else
or something like that
right and then you move down you moved
down to North otago way after that yeah
yeah so I was in the academy uh Hawkes
bag Academy and uh I was through I was
in The Magpie setup all the way until
they made like pick their final team and
I didn't make it
um and so yeah I got picked up by North
otago as a um the lone player um as a 19
year old and I remember Glenn Moore yeah
he was the one of the coaches and Barry
Matthews he's they call him rat oh yeah
I think he's still coaching down there
actually
um
top guy let me uh live on his dairy farm
had to pull the odd about 4am the old
morning just in my room
um also I was on the rubbish trucks oh
wow I was on the back of the rubbish
tracks
um I did that mostly I just remember
just thinking [ __ ] I'll do I'll do the
rubbish trucks and I'll get so fit I'll
just get soaked but but um like as a 19
year old I think you don't get any
fitter you kind of just hit a certain
point and you just 95 kilos dripping wet
so you're there's no there's no issues
um yeah I went down there and that's
when I rarely learned how to drink some
beers man like
um I was living with a guy called Josh
he's a legend I I catch up with him most
years we go for a hunt and stuff like
that
uh and uh you know I was living with him
on rats uh Dew farm he was the manager
there so um yeah got to see some
interesting things he showed me around
uh you know like it would be literally I
think we were getting I think the boys
were getting a hundred dollars a week
and
um I was getting paid 200 bucks a week
cash
I didn't even didn't even sort it out I
think they just decided to give it to me
because I was young buck yeah
um so I always just spent that all
straight on person that weekend you know
because you got you fly up on the Friday
you play the said there and you fly back
on the Sunday so yeah he was always a
big heavy weekend wherever you work but
man those boys I learned a lot from them
right what was your initiation into that
team as a young fellow
um brutal always nudity yeah always
nudity
um I actually can't remember to be
honest or maybe too many head knocks I
can't remember that type of Chateau um
you've done that many initiations
never hold back always just all go
right and then the following year you
made your Hawkes Bay team so um that was
what you're trying to make the year
before the following year you made it
yeah yeah I'll just um
I was lucky enough Craig Philpott was
the coach and um Danny Lee
and uh they gave me a shot and um
just basically I was just a sponge I was
behind Carlow oh Legend and and Brendan
O'Connor a couple of Legends drink
bottles of Wakefield
um
Mike Coleman so I've just had these
absolute Lads in front of me and I just
soaked it all up and just learned as
much as I could and
um was quite good going into the that
following year just had all the
confidence in the world I had nothing to
lose I just they just resigned me and um
I just felt heaps of confidence and I
wasn't
too worried about any um performance or
anything like that so it was a dream
result really yeah
um never I never
thought I would ever make it if you know
what I mean like I never never thought
oh [ __ ] like I'm like my goal was to
become a magpie I always wanted like I
wanted to but I never thought it would
actually happen and then when that
happened I thought oh [ __ ] well my next
goal would be try and make Super Rugby
not thinking that it would actually
happen it happened and then yeah then
then the kind of the rest happens from
there but um why didn't you think it was
going to happen like what what was sort
of holding you back with you I don't
know like I don't I definitely don't
lack any confidence that's for sure yeah
I just I just I don't know I just I just
said buddy Dairy Farmer from mid
Canterbury you don't hear too many
stories yeah
um I know uh Isaac Rossi was the he was
the legend back in ashburton because he
made it and uh who's the other guy man
there was a couple of there was a couple
of weed Lads there that cracked it
um but yeah just was like nah just was
pretty content with what I you know what
I'd done so I was just like oh well
you've always got to have a goal like
don't get me wrong like you've always
got to strive or something but
in all honesty I didn't really think it
was going to happen I was just like oh
well look I'm pretty stoked with what's
going on
um I just got qualified
um like my building apprenticeship so I
was just like
uh cracked it I'll crack that I'm I'm
only 20 years old I'm playing pro rugby
and I've Got My Ticket so I'm like [ __ ]
I'm sweet yeah yeah and then it was so I
think it was from memory like 2015 where
you really sort of kicked into gear I'm
guessing probably Kyle low and Stafford
left or you just got a few more
opportunities that yeah where
um I think you took Hawke's Bay to the
final losing to Tasman by a Keck
um from memory but I mean that was the
year where you were going to put your
hand up a situation
so many times
um yeah yeah so they're like the next
season I just felt so confident there
was no no issues I just um it all just
fell in my lap really like the first
game of the season was against
the Marcos
down there come off the bench I remember
Dougie Edmonds um was my roomie and um
he like gave me the John alomu like full
shave with the puff on the front and I
came off the bits this is like what I
mean like I just gave zero [ __ ] it was
no no drama it was all good
had that tough on the front
um and I came off the bench and just had
a Blinder and then I didn't really see
the the pine after that yeah but still
had Brynn O'Connor was there
um yeah so China was still playing Seven
he was Skipper and then
um I just basically had to learn to be a
six and they were Keen they were keen on
because they wanted to play two open
sides basically and lacking a little bit
in height but uh it was all good I just
made do and I was still pretty light you
know I was the only just over 100 clicks
so the big boys just threw me up there
you know dramas and sticks and always
put it right on the money
wait what a team what a team oh a hell
of a team what was it like after that
final
um obviously you would have been pretty
gattered but hawksbury by the sounds
yeah just like classic
um young fellow like I was pretty gutted
I think it was more guttered just for my
mate e because I could you know I could
see how dusty he was and how much it
meant to him
to be honest I don't really give a [ __ ]
I was just like no honestly I was just
like oh [ __ ] footy's footy like [ __ ]
happens
20 more years to go around that's kind
of my mentality and
um I was just once I kind of he was like
nah it's all good bro like we'll get on
the person I was like sweet real good he
really thinks okay everything's no good
he was no drivers boys were all good we
have a hell of a dude oh no doubt and
then you get a call into the canes is
this for a wider squad or was this a
full contract that was a wider Squad
yeah
um at that stage Arty had already said
to Plum Tree and body that um he was
going to play in the Olympics or
something like that yeah yeah it was
yeah so they needed another backup open
side because Cully was obviously the
next
um next of the rank
and so I was just going to cover for him
and I just had like the best season of
my life with
um the magpies in 2015. you've got
player to play of the season
um and everything so it was like just a
dream come true really
um basically just went there to soak it
all up again and I didn't expect too
much game time I think I played
four or five games
um
All Off the Bench but hey you wouldn't
change it for the world it was it was
pretty cool and then and then getting to
play in the semi-final that's right I
remember that the Chiefs um because
Kelly was had a niggle
and I was just praying that he was
because I remember the whole once we won
the semi other side off
come on Kelly oh
surely surely it's no good okay he's
sweet God damn it you got big minutes in
that game too from him right I did yeah
I did yeah yeah I remember uh always
always from about 15 minutes into the
game looking up at the coaches
right now
yeah
oh and then you said like Cali Kelly was
obviously back from injury so he was
back selected into the final and
um you missed out on the 23 but yeah um
still obviously got to be part of a
Super Rugby winning team and I don't
know if it's coincidence or not but it's
the only time they've won it the year
that you were there and I know I know
it's something something special about
me I don't know
but I don't know if I can claim that
because I've been some teams I'm like
I've been in a team we didn't win one
game one in the whole season
two of those I only give you one guess
who it was anyway
yeah true Stags I'm guessing oh America
oh I don't know right with Stags and
mistakes there's an 18 yeah
that's right we came back we leave it's
good up there tough yeah yeah so um
obviously a good year with the canes
every time you've got an opportunity you
stepped up what happened there like oh I
always sort of wanted to know what
happened there like you were playing
well you had a good year the following
year and then just weren't selected so
yeah I think um
I don't think I think my my downfall my
whole career probably has been my field
like just not putting
I don't know what the word is commitment
I think like I you know there was a lot
of [ __ ] I used to just tick boxes on me
and just like yeah yeah I did my Sprints
over the weekend but really no drama's
ticked just giving it that one but it
would show and like Fitness tests and
[ __ ] like that just full of [ __ ] just
live my best life basically
um
and I remember just always approaching
plum tree and just being like how am I
going like what do I need to be working
on are you always going to be like mate
everything's all good like you're going
sweet yeah you're only young you know
you've got either you're taking all your
opportunities like no dramas
everything's looking good
so we have our one-on-one at the end of
the year and he's like mate you [ __ ]
were terrible you should have been doing
this you'll be doing this man honestly I
was fired up in our in our review age
just stood up and I was like you piece
of [ __ ] probably didn't you probably
didn't sign me because of that because I
called him piece of [ __ ] Plum uh boardy
almost had to stand and just like stop
the situation because it [ __ ] it got
heated Man true Did you literally get it
oh true man that's dark because I was
like bro you know I wanted to learn yeah
don't get me wrong I shot myself in the
foot because I was you know like I
wasn't always doing what needed to be
done off field but um like when I was
asking the questions and stuff like that
you want your coach to be honest
insomnia is that uh ah it's all good
right almost
yeah it was so close I remember telling
what are you about it what do you just
saying ah it's all good mate no doubles
gave me a dart sweetness
what he would have been egging you off
oh he loves it but yeah no dramas
um but yeah so it was kind of like look
it's not the end of the world like it's
all good we still think you're a great
player but um you're just some stuff you
need to work on and then that 2017
season remember they changed the
breakdown rules and you had to you
couldn't pull for the ball
made this my game yeah I'm assuming like
you know I so I just I struggled
mentally just like with the confidence
side of things I just and then all the
pressure got to me hey like I realized
like [ __ ] I'm actually [ __ ]
an okay player man I made Super Rugby
and stuff like that played some games
like ah I need to be um I need to be
playing way business and the pressure
really got to me and uh
and yeah and then I went over with the
states and um and just tried to like
move on
move on from it all and
um and I was looking for gigs overseas
and was real real close to signing a
deal with um Newcastle Falcons oh yeah
and
um this is in 2018 and uh
yeah it was
um just about the sign of the dotted
line basically it was a few days out and
um in my my mum called me and well
actually my dad did
and dad did my dad's if anyone knows my
dad he's like six foot seven or six foot
eight
ginger in about 115 kilos studies of you
know he's a hot and he's a Dairy Farmer
his whole life he's a hard man with a
slight American twang to his accent and
uh he calls me up and he goes oh hey boy
everything how's it going over there
here no Swedish oh yeah I just want to
let you and he started crying and I was
like what's going on
let's get on here well mandiba cries but
I could tell the phone I couldn't see
him but he was could hear it in his
voice he's like oh mum's got Ken so I'm
freaking out
um so yeah I just packed everything up
and came home and um
and yeah basically that stage is miter
10 couples
just about to start and I was lucky to
pick up a gig with the Stags in 2018 and
that's where it started sure so did you
get over to Newcastle were you actually
there no no I wasn't I wasn't I was in
the US
and yeah it was just um trying to just
plan my next move basically had my wife
back in New Zealand and she was my wife
Abby um she was waiting for me to see
what's going on so she didn't go to
America with you when you're back
um yeah she she came home for a little
bit in San Diego with Jack just for a
little bit and then wasn't really her
thing the big city and all that so sent
her home and I knew you like look I'm
gonna there's gonna be Something's Gonna
Pop up anyway so just hold fire and
we'll sort it out and then that all
happened so then
this is crazy on off um home after that
and um
that's when I uh
started struggling mentally like big
time I um started
um
didn't know if it was at um depression
but it might be a lot of slightly
depression but it was definitely anxiety
I used to just freak out for no reason I
didn't know what it was about why it was
and started seeing a um a psych and um
the shrink and uh yeah just um just just
explained to me basically
you know it's just a season in life I
think like most people go through this
side of things you're not you should
just think I was like this doesn't
happen to anyone I never even I didn't
even know mental health was a thing then
honestly I didn't even yeah just one of
those kids grew up just everything was
just mint yeah everything was so meant
and all of a sudden life just got so
tough and wanted to I played at this
massive high level
and I wanted to just stay there but it
just wasn't happening because I just got
like this honestly I'd gone Hawke's Bay
Gone on that starting every game
hurricanes oh and then Eagles and then
just like had nothing like just nothing
so so I just was struggling man and at
that time it was like I thought it was
my identity and I thought that's who I
was I was Tony Lambo and the rugby
player so and then my mum being sick as
well as a mama's boy so I just struggled
man big time but um had just had awesome
people around me who helped that I was
just being honest with how I was feeling
and I was struggling and um and stuff
like that and yeah no it's um definitely
got got through it and got out the other
side and um and always been I guess I
was really good at like after and and
during like got really good at
understanding it and and what was
triggering those feelings and and
um all these different emotions that
going through my head and why that
possibly could be and then you know some
of my friends started going through it
and and other people I hadn't met but I
was always pretty Keen to reach out
because I felt like I had a little bit
of experience and a bit of knowledge so
um
yeah so and to be honest I do say this
to a lot of people like I um I wouldn't
change it I wouldn't actually say I wish
that never happened to me because um it
may be the man I am today I am
definitely stronger for it and um
yeah it was just uh it was like it was
like it was like a blessing in disguise
you would some would say like that's how
I would describe it you know like I
learned so much from it and it helped me
grow and mature and and sort me out
apart from um the push drinking stuff
really you can sort that out at all but
uh enjoying life we've just gotta live
life to its fullest yeah so was this
mainly when you're in America by
yourself or is this once you'd moved
down to Southland once I moved back home
um and then the struggles with the South
and thing I seem to be fine when I was
playing when I was like in the
environment
um you know
um doing what I believed was what I was
meant to be doing and stuff like that so
I felt fine and then when I'm like
playing every week trying to impress
super coaches and trying to get a gig
and it wasn't happening you know and
you're getting
you know as you would know you get
awesome feedback from your um from your
agent but you know good mate you're
going to get a phone call from the uh
from the blues coaches any day now and
you just get nothing you piece of [ __ ]
I'm not gonna say who it was I've
changed agents since then I don't have
them
he was the man that
you did you were playing really good
footy for um mistakes at the time hey
and I remember like everyone like the
whole I remember reading articles
everyone was predicting you to be picked
up and everyone was everyone was so
confused why you weren't in a squad and
um it must have been hard for you
yeah I think that like you said yes that
was what was making it harder you see
like I was like well I'm not the only
one that believes in myself here like
you know everyone else was kind of
seeing it
um but I think it was maybe it was just
the style of player that I am I think I
was um just a bit of an old school
hard-nosed type player and I think
um a lot of teams were just looking for
the young kid out of school rasley
um Artie Sevilla bloody fight play you
know like there's
Addy's one in a billion player like you
don't you're not going to get that color
uh you're not just going to get him
popping out every every buddy City but
um
yeah so I don't know look end of the day
it didn't happen and um but I did
struggle with it but um yeah over the
years it probably was uh once yeah like
it kind of it was a good couple of years
and it it took me to kind of figure it
all out for sure did the fact that you
were capped with um USA make that way
harder for you to pick up a Super Rugby
contract yeah yeah that definitely made
um things have a lot harder I remember I
was um over in Argentina with the us and
we just finished our final game and my
agent rang me up and said hey
um Jimmy Lynch uses uh dislocated his
knee or broken leg or something like
that it was shoulder not sure
um and the hollanders want you in for
the season I put you on a full gig or
sort of Tony Brown Rings me up just
before the flight and he's like hey mate
um real Keen to get you here you like
your style
um we're just having we're just sorting
out um something with New Zealand Rugby
at the moment but don't worry get on the
plane
you've got a 15-hour flight
um get on the plane and when you land
um we'll give you a couple of days your
family and then you'll get down there
land first message I get from agent was
like not
um Holland has already had their quota
for their international players and they
wouldn't give you a dispensation all
right
um Joey wheeler I remember because he
played under a UK passport or something
so he went under as a um
as a foreign player so that's what
[ __ ] me out did he I was like an
[ __ ] but uh something
[Laughter]
that is brutal though fly you back for a
kick and then nothing I know yeah
because I I was planning on going back
to the States
um just for a couple of weeks just to
have a bit of a bender with the boys
because we're just basically had a big
tour I think it was like two months so
we were just I was like Keen to go back
to the States just for a couple of weeks
bit of a bender and then
go back home
when when you sign with this or when you
obviously played your first game with
the state so that ever come into your
mind around how hard it was going to be
for you to then make super and all the
sort of things that come with playing
internationally mate I didn't even know
it was a thing honestly I didn't I just
was like just young and just like I was
like this is what was going through my
head I remember it was in the hurricanes
and I was like
John plum tree gets me in his office
he's like hey uh my brother-in-law John
Mitchell is the head coach of the US
team he's real Keen to get you um
real king to get you into this team
obviously you're dead being born and
raised in the States you know you can
you can get you know you're straight in
I was like oh yeah cool and he's like oh
you know like have a good think about it
anyway and I was like what was the only
like kind of
any backlash or anything tonight he's
like um
is like oh mate just being a young kid I
think I just blanked out because I've
already made up of my mind that I was
going to do it so I just probably didn't
listen he probably didn't tell me
um
and I just remember thinking oh well
Addie's just made the all black same
canes in there and I think macaw was
still playing for the All Blacks at that
stage and I was just like the next step
is the All Blacks I don't think this
will ever happen like Artie is a far
better player than me you know there's
so many other loose foods in this
country that would make the All Blacks
before I would sell us like now look
this is not going to happen so the next
piece option was be in the US and I get
to do some traveling and um and do do
all that type of stuff so yeah I just
yeah that was it made up my mind and um
debut game against Italy it's called a
try on debut
remember we just lost to buy like two
points I think we uh we're trying to
milk the penalty at the end to win the
game but it's never happened but uh yeah
how was it over there like how did it
compare obviously you're coming from the
Hurricanes into USA Rugby team what was
the level
well now it wasn't to have a lot of
difference in terms of like how we were
going to plan [ __ ] because John Mitchell
literally John Plum G sent him the
Kane's game plan and the statues and the
plays and everything so I was like yeah
boys rounding up come around EB boys
that's how we do it back and back home
uh martyville was our Ford's coach at
the time as well so he's an absolutely
understood chat with him very often
um and uh so yeah they were just trying
to basically just trying to play exactly
what the canes I did struggle at the
start just trying to like because I've
been playing with the cane so you know
and these guys are most of these guys
are all blacks and stuff like that so
just playing training with these very
high skilled players and going to the
states
um was kind of tough you know like it
was
not saying it was terrible I definitely
like um good players and stuff they've
picked the best of the best in in the
States but um yeah just struggled with
uh with with the the level of um skill
and stuff like that at some points and
their understanding of the game kind of
as well I think that's just basically
just been in our blood forever you know
like we're just born and born into it so
it all comes off but these guys a lot of
these guys are playing American football
and [ __ ] like that for a long time yeah
through high school and then and then
they realize oh [ __ ] football's not
working out I'll give rugby a crack in
so still pretty fresh chops when it when
it came down to it and you've obviously
been there from the start of the mlr to
um what it is now pretty much so have
you found the sort of growth of rugby
over there yeah no massively I think um
like back when it was their first season
with San Diego
um it was still real fresh everyone was
trying to still figure out where their
home stadiums were going to be where's
everyone's training it was just like hey
if I can just have a team here this is
your team you have this team
so sort your own [ __ ] out like you sort
out where you're going to trade and
stuff like that
um I remember Landing there with Abby
and Jack and uh we were supposed to have
a car there at the airport wasn't a car
I had to get an Uber
Uber to this address we get there bro
and there's another couple living in the
house
sure and I'm like what the
what's going on here
bring up the ring up the manager I'm
like bro there's like another family
living in this house and he's like yeah
that's all good isn't it and he's a kiwi
guy and I was like [ __ ] no would you do
that back home no you wouldn't for like
get me out of here man this [ __ ] I
didn't come here for this like you know
like you guys are promising me all the
stuff and you're delivering Donuts like
you're just giving me nothing
come on Mrs is like
I can get me out of this [ __ ] home now
oh I could imagine right it's hard
enough moving to a new country level and
having that sort of debacles on arrival
oh you know and it's like from Auckland
to L.A
was like a 11 12 hour flight and then
you've got like a 20 minute little
flight from LA to San Diego so you just
wrecked yeah the young fellas flying up
on the airport so you just
oh sweet you know I took a sleeping pill
I was no dramas Mrs had to sort that out
but so she was just in a dark place
there just like get me out of this
[ __ ] shell so he lived in a hotel for
like it was like a nice hotel too lived
in a real nice hotel for like a month
and then Abby was like I'm out of here
I'm gone is that when she went back to
New Zealand and you stayed there yeah
in the hotel for the rest of the season
um or did you move back to your mate's
Place yeah no no I stayed in the hotel
the whole season oh yeah yeah
sorry I don't live in the hotel the
whole time
I for the last I think was the last
month or so I moved into this kiwi guys
Place loaded as dude he lived in um
it was called Cardiff it's called
Cardiff oh yeah in in San Diego it's
where Danny Lee's living now actually
and uh he had this massive Mansion man
and um but he had this like guest house
like a separate like second dwelling
type thing
it was cut it out it was awesome so I
lived there and this is kiwi's guy his
name is Willie Den
and uh smokes a pack of dogs every hour
type dude it's got an epic man cave like
down in this basement down below his
house big pool had like had like pit
Hawks and Falcons and [ __ ] like that
had like epic big cars so his his gig
was um
he was like an electrician and wired up
like each city did Kobe Bryant's house
this is always it was alive back then
um
um wired up like a home theater system
like big like literally a movie theater
in his house yeah did all that [ __ ]
crack Legend still talk to him all the
time absolutely Egypt all right yeah 60
years old just weapon shouted me a trip
to Las Vegas
that stays there right that is loving
another drink did you host um court
session in his man cave mate we had
heaps of Court sessions I'm not even
kidding
he gave all the boys round to his house
just get tanked up and the boys loved it
because it was unlimited person you just
go go for it yeah
and he hit a big pump you know his man
cage was just a big punting room the
boys are just slapping away just like
bidding on the dogs on the horses all
sorts of [ __ ] it was Unreal right that
is unreal so did you go back there the
following year you changed clubs didn't
yeah yeah I can't even remember the
process sale
um
2018 then I did my ankle
and then so I had like six mile had
surgery then I had six months off and
then I got caught into the uh Melbourne
Rebels
and um as like an injury cover but was
also injured so it was real weird like
and I told them they rang me up they're
like hey mate like how's your injury
going wherever and I was like yeah if I
can it's [ __ ] like yeah let's get in
here though like Yeah Eddie a week now
type thing so they got me in there to
help me rehab and sorted me up but um I
just trained in there and uh got
absolutely hooked up by this guy that
owned this Rugby Club over there was
loaded and
yeah that was that was a good time over
in Melbourne it was it was great good
experience I mean you get all the
hookups with all the loaded kids oh man
yeah well this guy's uh he's like a Sri
Lankan or something and owns the
moorabbin Rams uh his name's Arvin Arvin
David absolute weapon and uh yeah you
just said oh look you come play for my
club
I'll give you the sick apartment and
I'll give you a car and all good so it's
getting paid by the Melbourne Rebels and
I was also getting paid by them because
I I was just playing I was playing each
weekend so he's paying I think he's
paying like 500 bucks a week cash on top
of everything else oh yeah
creaming at me other than that living
the dream and I was like just doing
rehab I was hobbling every weekend like
definitely why I've got to get my ankle
fixed now because I I came back way too
early my ankle was rooted yeah but you
never played for the rebels did you no I
remember like one of the first weeks I
was there it was the first game against
the canes in Wellington okay and uh and
I was training in the like 23 but they
had me bracketed with another player and
so I still traveled and flew back and
stayed in Wellington and um yeah
unfortunately I didn't they were just
like oh now we're gonna go for different
options and see this yeah I guess so
that would have been good but you were
there with you were with them for the
whole season
yet went for the whole season because my
debut game was against the Melvin Rebels
for the Hurricanes oh yeah so then I was
thinking [ __ ] my first debut game for
the rebels is going to be against Cairns
you can't read about it you can't read
about it
but yeah that was it was a good time
right and another thing I'm Keen to talk
to you about is obviously going to the
Rugby World Cat with USA
um in Japan must have been some
experience and I've always sort of
wondered what it's like I've obviously
speak to guys and all blacks and some of
the bigger teams that go to the Rugby
World Cup but what's it like going
um with the USA team like what's your
sort of expectations and how does it all
work uh my expectations were there like
I just went there to win like I honestly
I went here to try and win
that's my mentality every time I play
rugby I just wanna
put everything I can out there to try
and try and win the game but I thought
like definitely could at least win one
maybe even two I remember uh the first
game was against England and man we were
down by like five five points I think
with about 20 to go and then
kind of uh blew out in the last like
10-15 minutes
um yeah they put another two or three
tries on us but like stayed right in it
and then I remember against France we
were beating them at one point and then
they kind of claw back and then
beat us in the last 10 so minutes again
and then Argentina they actually
thrashed us and then Tonga were beating
them all the way through and then to
luciferianu that's right that's the just
like pulled some [ __ ] out of his ass as
he does because he's an absolute freak
um and yeah they scored on like under
the sticks and kicked the goal to win it
so it was like yeah I was gutted man
honestly because I was like I wanted a
wanted to just win a game and qualify
straight away for the next World Cup and
[ __ ] like that but um yeah I was pretty
good at my I remember thinking after the
World Cup like
um
I was a bit gutted into like a few of
the boys on the team and I felt like
only a few of us that really actually
wanted a window a lot of them were like
a few of the other boys were just stoked
with just being there and that might be
hard for a few boys to hear that but
that's just me being honest and that's
just who I am so just straight up but um
you know I just I thought that yeah a
few of the boys were just happy to be
there and we're just clipping the ticket
whereas um there's a few of us that
really really wanted to really wanted to
win you know and I think that's kind of
what could have been the difference
they're not qualified yet eh and it's
looking unlikely that they're going to
or they're still no no that's what they
are so they beat they beat um Hong Kong
and they beat Kenya I've got to win one
more they're in Dubai at the moment
living the dream so they've got a I
don't know who the last game's against
um someone someone weird but uh they've
got a they've got to win their game
they'll win all three and they qualify
yeah so
should be all good and if they qualify
you won't you won't be tempted to put
the boots back off for one more right it
would be so hard to lose 10 kilos like
I don't think I've ever lost 10 kilos
before I've lost five kilos for the
blues I uh
remember the blues I
um come back from covert and again you
know my field [ __ ] I was ticking boxes
saying I was doing all the ring and all
the yo-yos and beat juice and [ __ ] I was
supposed to be doing out on the footy
film with my mask on
um you know I just was ticking box and I
came in there another like five kilos
heavier
they made me lose five kilos in two
weeks wow yeah yeah and I ran like a it
was like a five minute Thirty Something
Bronco it was ridiculous and these guys
are like mate you're running like
you're running like a 502 or something
like that before you left
I was gonna say yeah look I might have
lied
I don't think we were coming back
honestly I don't think I thought covert
rooted everyone without hearing about
every all these comps Premiership
everything they're just calling it quits
on it and I thought we're not coming
back so like why am I going to waste my
time doing [ __ ] that I absolutely hate
oh sure that came back to bite you
[ __ ] I tell you what because I was
before covert I was negotiating two more
years signing two more years with them
oh that's right they came back and
they're like yeah beat it I was like
damn it mate I was wondering what
happened there too because even when you
that year when you got the opportunities
mate you were playing some good footy
again eh yeah like um Tom country he's
he's a good man and uh yeah he he loved
my style of play and
he's seeing my game against England
um and I played really well in that game
and he basically
he called me before the game and said I
look like we're having a look at you and
um you know you just play really well in
the world cup and uh and we'll and then
I'll you know we'll see how we go and
then yeah after the England game he rung
me like I was in The Sheds he was in
Japan he watched the game oh yeah
because uh like yeah we want to sign you
right now so I was like sweet
um and yeah like you said I took all my
opportunities and put a lot of um
competitive airjet trainings with the
blues and and I feel
without
you know sounding real cocky or anything
but I felt like I was um
a major like difference in that full
pack and changing and and helping uh not
only the culture but like their
competitiveness at trainings and not
bringing the best out and some guys like
definitely when I first got there I
remember just like doing we're doing a
hardcore contact session and
I was going pretty hard I remember one
of the boys saying to me um bro why are
you like take it easy
you know like where are we here trying
to survive and I was like look nah bro
I've been told like the coaches have
told me man this is what this is what's
wrong you guys are like just [ __ ]
ticking boxes bro
we're training from the ultimate yeah
foreign
yeah
um so yeah that basically what happened
I just again just
cocked it all up
um
but again I wouldn't change it it
shouldn't change for the world
everything happens for a reason so um
help me uh
figure out you know like
um I've just gotta I'm getting old now I
need to sort out the sort out what the
future is for me not only me but for my
wife and my and my boys so um
by this so Johnny appears only had the
one but Abby was pregnant with Kwame our
youngest it's almost two
um and yeah and that in 2020 I got to
they asked me to Captain the Stags and
um
and that's where the the massive like
pride and like just like I love I love
talk Spain don't get me wrong I've
always felt like my heart's been hoop
black and white but
just playing for that team and getting
to lead it was just something different
and I think like I always said oh well
I'll never play for everyone else again
like I always play for the Stags um
but I guess you know
um
[ __ ] life goes on and eventually like if
you if I was still playing then if
someone offered me a contract will be in
there but you know like it's yeah
um it was just yeah I love my time down
there and I felt like we definitely made
a difference you know we didn't want to
gain for like two or three years or
something
um consecutively and then our first game
was against Hawke's Bay wild team down
and invercargill and we and we beat them
for you know it was like 30 game like
losing streak or something like that and
we beat them and they went on to win
it'll be in the finals or something that
year so
I think we won like four
maybe three or four games that season so
that was epic and then 21
we uh we didn't win as many gains but
just the way the whole comp worked out
and we ended up making the semis against
um against uh that's right
taranaki and uh that's the old uh yeah
go on
shove it up your ass though
as I'm concerned oh one of the great
aftermatch speeches so talk to me about
that like were you guys getting a fair
bit of hate up and uh leading man we
were getting heaps of Hate by people
being like oh they don't deserve to be
there like I've only won like two games
or three games or something so
why do they deserve to be in the
semi-finals you know
um I think the other team that was
potentially could have been there was
like counties or men or two or something
and we'd beaten them in on points or
something so that's how it worked out or
we'd spilled more trials or something so
um
yeah we we made it and uh that's and we
were copying it man honestly
it was it was it sucked and it was the
thing is we played him the week before
like literally the week before the semi
and we freaking give them a good nudge
and then see me final was like passing
down with rain and we were just like
they're just robbing your hands getting
a lot this is we we're born for like
down south this is we bought him this
[ __ ] we're freaking born in this [ __ ]
you know
so um yeah I can't remember what the
score was now but
um yeah we only we only just lost and
you know I remember I can't remember
yeah he he asked me you know he'd been
copying a bit of I can't remember how it
went but yeah
shove it up your ass
honestly I don't get one hate message
after that yeah I got hundreds of
messages from people being like good on
you boy yeah good [ __ ]
right it's always good when someone
speaks what's on their mind I mean
there's just not enough of it in the
game so it's always refreshing when
someone just says whatever comes yeah
foreign
oh mate what a what a career but how do
you look back on your career like
um obviously you've done you've done a
lot yeah yeah like I'm extremely proud
and um
definitely like real grateful you know
like
um there's been some huge
like people in my life that helped me
throughout it all and some guys that
gave me the opportunities and believed
in me and stuff like that so um yeah I
definitely wouldn't have accomplished
all of that stuff without those people
and you know one of them being um Ebby
my wife and uh Joe Payton who first
called me into the um
into the academy back in the day and
then Tom country believe in me and Danny
Lee is still to this day my the best
coach I've ever had in my life and
um I think he deserves higher honors
than um coaching at San Diego I think he
really enjoys it over there but
um yeah I just yeah we're all grateful
but um but definitely proud of what what
I've accomplished and definitely didn't
think I was going to get get that far
that's for sure but um yeah it's a mess
of things you know like winning the uh
the ram Philly Shield
um two times three times gotta I know
I'm like well if I just want to be this
year
don't go on now do it now I know he's
sent in the question but you might as
well share it oh
so being the young guy in the team was
my first year of the magpies
and tag I have the shield and we're
playing them at um Forsyth Bar Stadium
and uh I actually never got on the field
I was on the bench and it was such a
tight game you won it and because I was
the youngest in the team I had to look
after the shield
so anyway
um me being me just hooked into the piss
uh we had a short turnaround we had we
had counties like three day four days
later but it was like [ __ ] out with the
Hawks May haven't won the shield in like
50 something years
so uh we well and truly hooked into I
remember Sumo Stevenson was on the piss
with us and
we this is out the game we had um I was
with a few other guys I'm not going to
name any more Sumo and Bug it off at
this stage and uh and we
we were on the we're on the street
walking some of the like the flats and
stuff like that and um there was this
random chick hanging around bro like
hanging around would not leave us alone
and she's like
I just wanna I just wanna have sex with
the shield I just wanna I just want to
[ __ ] on The Shield or something like
that I'm like on the road lying down
someone you know oh I just grabbed say
that you know I'm 22 years old or 20
years old I don't even know how old I
was just
doing the dream and I remember waking up
in the morning
and we're like [ __ ] we've got to go and
I've still got this thing they had
strapping tape strapping taped it to me
like X-Men who restrict my beard skin
so I had this thing strapped to me I
woke up in the morning I'm like ah wolf
get this off so I look half respectful
get my kid on we're in the bath
traveling to the
um
generally interlock managers like
where the [ __ ] are like three or four of
those little Shields
the little shields on it yeah
I like looking at like oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
just panicking all the way and they're
going how we because we're going to get
to the airport and there's going to be
thousands of people there taking photos
and the one thing they're going to
notice is there's Shields
what kind of store are we going to come
up with here
and I'm like yeah I'm like no you guys
figure it out I've got to just sit at
the plant and back to the plane here you
guys sort this out
doing a plane fell asleep forgot about
it all landed and I'm walking and we're
walking down the like the ramp and you
could just see the flashing lights
cameras and [ __ ] going off in the
airport
and I put my hand in my pocket and I'm
like what's that pulled out all of the
shields they were in my pocket from the
night before so we're like [ __ ] turned
around get back in the plane hiding
someone got any gums sticky tape
anything sticking it on
oh my Lord there's some there's been
some [ __ ] that's happened on that shoe
and I give you the tip oh gee that is
good
yeah and then we lost it like and then
we lost it like four days later shortest
rain ever it was Moon must have been
your captain that year was he yeah
oh right that's one of the greats one of
the great stories
but he sends in some good questions to
Kevin we might as well carry on with the
rest of the questions while we're at it
because we did get heaps of them and
like I said a lot of them around um the
Press but it's good stuff that's the
stuff that's the start I enjoyed that
one okay this one's best Cordy stitch up
oh
yeah I'd so 2018 so obviously just
playing for the Stags we didn't win a
game so I fly back home and Hawkes Bay
were done the finals or whatever and
smudgy Ash sticks and Rings me up he's
like hey
you Keen to come now according I was
like [ __ ] yeah I'm kidding to come to
recording no dramas and he's like bro
we've got you a morph suit
hit the toe
and No One's Gonna know you just
basically you can do whatever the [ __ ]
you want in the court session not how to
talk though don't talk none of your [ __ ]
just do whatever you want
no dramas and I was like yeah [ __ ]
sweet this is me all over and he's like
and the boys have got to guess who it is
I knew the whole team everyone [ __ ]
knew exactly who it was and that fat
looking guy with a [ __ ] up nose I'm
like
awkward body position like they knew it
was me straight away so anyway it was
sitting in the courty and um it was real
important so they're doing the um you
know call outs like how are you calling
out that's and they had this massive
like Barrel in the Middle full of
all sorts of bodily fluids and all sorts
of stuff
so anyway it's like real meaningful and
quiet someone's listening it's being
real serious conversation I just got up
and just elbow dropped slammed into the
bucket full of stupids everything
I'm just covering the stuff didn't know
what it was and they're all sitting on
like plastic seats you know the plastic
seats I started walking around karate
kicking them and breaking them all off
so they're just all fall back and smack
their hits
and what the stitch up was is that at
one stage I just couldn't remember
what's going you know like you just like
oh out the back taking a piss and one of
the boys
let a like a lighter or someone's having
a dart and whatever was on my back was
flammable
and they lit it and it just went off and
my whole body true was on fire and I
didn't because me being me I wasn't
wearing underwear nothing
oh this is wearing anything under this
morphsuit and then I had hectic Burns
all over my body yeah did yeah it was
that far out well obviously how did you
how did you put it out I just like just
have the ground and roll man it's just
hit the ground and roll oh
it bear on me like sort it sort it out
and I just like you know I couldn't feel
anything but like like in terms of pains
was that was it
choker I just was like
yeah how bad were the birds like have
you got like beer and scars or yeah the
bad ones are on my ass say like on the
top of the top of my cheek my ass cheeks
now that is a stitch up yeah
oh man that is loose okay love it okay
next one how'd you get the nickname
kitty dog yeah I think look I think it
might have been a bit of a dog back in
the day
and uh
yeah and I think it just resembled the
way I played and everything like that
and uh having mates like Eli West uh
Gilly's Kaka and all that like do
Gibbons all those boys who got good
friends of mine all good Havelock men
that were played for Havelock
um just decided look he's just he's
could he he's
thoughtie dog and then obviously Ella
Dyson Mark Abbott and then call me dog
dog because basically that's what you're
saying and then
James Parsons at uh the blues you know
she's all ahead just walked around
calling me dog dogs because it just
didn't make sense to cause someone could
eat all because you just like a seed
you're just calling them bulk dog but uh
it sounded way cooler
oh if you're an Afghan next one this is
a good one tell us about the fight
against the turbos when you got a red
this is one of the great fights
oh I've just we've been a [ __ ] season
day like I mean we beat the Stags
first round and I remember I just like I
did like a grade
three or four of my AC joint and like
literally it was like real bad and uh
had the first week or two off and I
remember just like them jabbing at every
game after that and um we didn't win a
game the whole season and it was just
one of those just the culture started
going out the window I remember the week
before the last game we obviously went
making the semis he called us nothing
and smudges like bro
it gets the boys in bro we gotta like
you're a senior player in this team now
you're gonna like rev these boys up you
know so like my big thing was just like
having each other's backs and just
getting a bit of monger and just like if
someone's gonna do it like have a fight
we all need to jump in for the fight so
no one gets red carded
and it was supposed to and in my head
I'm going right I'm going to start a
fight but I'm not going to do it until
like
if I'm still on in the last like 30 20
to 30 to go in the second half well
that could be days it's like 20 30 20 30
minutes into the first half
we've got a scrum and there's this guy
that placed them into the twos I can't
actually remember his name for men or
two turbos and he was English or
Scottish or something and um I just
didn't like the guy but from what I
understand he's actually a bloody nice
dude and don't get me wrong like for
everyone out there if you know me on the
field I'm a prick but off the field I
love you like there's no there's no
there's no dramas there but I just like
playing against the guy I just did not
like this guy in any way I mean Gareth
Evans
we pump them in the scrum and we reved
up
and they're up on the scoreboard and I'm
going to start right I've got to do
something to fire these boys up
so Gareth threw the balloon and he kind
of went through and I went you could
watch it on YouTube if you like and I
reached like around the back of um
Garris like went around him and just
clocked them and then just like elbowed
them at the same time
and uh and then yeah it was all on and
then kind of like it's right on the
sideline so the cameraman's like there's
two cameramen there there's one filming
me and then there's the other one and
then the background you can still see
the other camera man just like two
meters away just send them
and he hits me like I'm underneath him
and he's and we're falling and we hit
the ground and then I quickly spun on
top of them and uh and uh gave him a few
few good ones on the ground and then the
flying Fijian comes flying from the wing
bro and just kicked me in the head
fully just like we watch a video just
flies on bow and I'm like holy get up
and I'm in bed like Eli and them aren't
big Scrappers or anything Brad Weber's
in there like all those boys and they
and then you're dusting them up and I'm
like get me in there jump in just on him
as well and uh
yeah I got six weeks
um initially but then um because
uh of my impeccable history I got uh I
got it deducted I got two weeks off so I
got
um four weeks and I was supposed to go
on tour
with the US four weeks later and what I
did is I rung up
um the manager for the US and I was like
mate there's a way around this I reckon
what we do is I have signed a contract
with the protein over there and I just
get suspended for those four gains
leading up
so I just missed nothing oh right
Chicago Lions shout out Chicago live new
to them
but I signed a contract missed four
games no drama straight in there playing
the first game for the Eagles oh mate
beat the system Darcy Swain like mate I
love that yeah that is a loose yarn as
well mate you've got some of the great
loose yards okay next one favorite
teammate to get on the piss with
oh that's a tough one man honestly
that's a real tough one
that's you know obviously playing for so
many so many themes you know you've come
across
some good ones uh I think like I'll pick
one on each team I think
it's Ken Dolan I uh came Dolan for the
US
he was my roomie we always became
roomies
um
the magpies
um would be a couple bid May and and uh
and Gareth yeah
um
cell phone sticks oh gee that's a tough
one those boys know how to drink some
dust down there
uh
um yeah with monarchy Shelby Ricky
doesn't play there anymore
Mike McKee those type boys tidy yeah
Ethan the group goes pretty good on the
first time
okay last question for you best piece of
advice you had for a woodland listener
that's a good one
um thanks
[Laughter]
oh yeah I think um just Life's a ride
you know it's it's a ride and it's going
to have its ups and downs and I think
you just got to um
um just takes it as it comes you know
like don't worry about tomorrow like I
remember hearing this this um don't
worry about tomorrow for today has
enough problems of its own so you know
not done getting stressed about out
about the future let's just focus on
today get get the jobs done for today
and then um tomorrow's stuff will come
so uh it's something that I kind of
um
you kind of follow and stuff like that I
think it just gotta well running a
business obviously you've got to think
about the future until I live and uh and
organize them plan ahead but in terms of
yeah just
um General Life stuff I think you just
just take it as it comes it's a ride
it's it's like I said it's got its up
and down ups and downs stay in the
moment mate I love that oh yeah mate
what a way to finish one of the greatest
podcasts yet I reckon that was
um it's Jesus some Yarns in there I
thought there would be that but I think
you've Blown Away even my expectation uh
obviously you're a champion lad played
for so many teams uh obviously had the
pleasure of playing with you for a year
at the canes and
um what a lad you were but really
appreciate you coming on the podcast
sharing some of your stories and
um awesome to hear that
um post 40's gone well so far and along
May that continue cheers absolute
pleasure and I'm stoked I got the call
up I've been I've been hoping I'd get
the call up one day to the what a LED
podcast I'm glad it's finally happened
because geez that was worth it pigeon
thanks Jimmy you're a lad guys thanks
for listening if you got this far I'm
guessing you enjoyed it and if you could
do a met me and if you could do me a
massive favor and share this episode on
whatever social media platform you have
or go tell a friend about this podcast
that would be very much appreciated love
your work
[Music]
[Music]
foreign